this summer we had 117 16 interns and I
took some of them to lunch and I said so
how did you get interested in film and
they all said and I was stunned because
they all said watching TCM and the same
students I had students who watched it
and I think Robert has a lot to do with
that in that his introductions and his
poise gets you to tells you why you
might enjoy what's coming up next he
always had a way of making it feel like
go on this journey you'll love it and
I'm really happy because again I think
it's important to see films made by
other generations because we learned
that we keep making the same mistakes or
maybe in a better way we learned that
we're all human and that it's been
carried from generation to generation so
was there anything that you felt about
Roberts and anybody and that you felt
about his approach to films that or
particular film of yours something he
said about your work that you thought
nobody has ever picked up on that
certainly when I met him had seen all
about Eve about 15 times and he's told
me right off and I went anyone who could
see one film 15 at that time I'm sure he
saw many more times after that but that
was when I met him he was staying at
Jane dar Wells house
you all remember Jane he had them yet he
had the ability to pick that too
he could see that that maybe I mean I
couldn't see it I mean he made me aware
of so many things in film and in the
structure and how it was put together
and the feeling about it I mean Bob
there's the trustee of the trust is here
tonight from New York he flew in Robert
Friedman I wish you would stand please
because he was a kind man to you all
these years
and and he he he saw the black book and
he saw the pages and he saw the notes
and he saw all of these things and we
wondered where they will go and who will
be able to see that work and it's all in
various stages of what's going to happen
hopefully some some of it gets to the
Academy but he was meticulous you talk
about in every movie every play every
theater he went to when he was at in in
Washington